well if you are ready to become a part
of a financial institution that has
great rates cool benefits and
personalized service it's time to join
silver state schools credit union the
sponsors of our next segment mercedes
talked to president and ceo scott r
kills about how they helped their
members and the community
so excited to see you again scott it was
so great to see you at the grand opening
of the aliante bridge and something that
actually we talked about was the
that silver state schools credit union
just awarded to 10 local students tell
me more about that so silver state
schools credit union's values education
as you know and we've awarded over eight
hundred thousand dollars in scholarship
actually since 1989
and through our people over profit
foundation this year we awarded high
school seniors with two thousand dollar
scholarships renewable for four years
and so that's a total of eight thousand
dollars per senior uh towards their uh
higher education tuition
so these students are exceptional in so
many ways and and i got to tell you the
confidence the competition is
unbelievable and this goes from students
having perfect gpas to being superb
athletes to being active community
volunteers and often often i'm a mixture
of all of those and so i i always tell
the the students they put me to shame
and what i did in my high school career
and so you know i and i at mercedes i'd
love to tell you about all of them but
there's just not enough time but i'm i'm
really thrilled that silver state
schools credit union for our people over
proper foundation is assisting these
students and continuing their education
and i'd like to graduate i can
congratulate all the local high school
graduates this year i love how you
support the students in our community
let's talk a little business though here
um i know a lot of people have been
talking about finding a cars it's not
been easy with the ongoing inventory
shortages and the rising interest rates
what can silver state schools credit
union do
one option that's available is
refinancing your current vehicle so
silver state schools credit union has a
program called the adc auto loan and
that stands for a better car and that
gives you an opportunity to save up to
two percent off your current auto loan
rate when you refinance your auto loan
with us um and through the end of june
you can actually benefit further by
getting the 90-day first payment payment
vacation and that's pretty great during
the summer that gives you the the
ability to you know to really help out
and so this program allows you to lower
your interest rate reduce your monthly
auto loan payment that's upon the bills
or add to your savings account and um
obviously all those loans are subject to
approval of course but to learn more
about the program just visit
silverstatecu.com
abc loans for details i i'm a member of
silver state schools credit union my
family their members and uh the question
i get all the time is even though you
guys are obviously you have deep roots
in the education community
membership is open to almost everyone
can you tell me a little bit more about
that as you mentioned while schools is
in our name anyone can become a member
um so if you don't meet the membership
qualifications that are tied to the
education institutions or advanced
educational world you can become a
member by making a one-time donation to
vegas pbs which really supports them as
well as the rest of the community
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring this segment call
702-733-8820
or visit
silverstatecu.com be right back